lock him to this video the part 20 he
had 20 of this pre World Championship
match serious the final part now
presenting the 10th game by the
Challenger Magnus Carlsen and there's
already explained yesterday I'm going to
go for both players finest hour enum in
the final video of the series of course
for a player like Carson who is 22 years
old it's a bit difficult to talk about
the finest hour it's probably yet to
come um and um it's also not also not so
easy to to choose yet for example
fantastic tournament in in this year
2013 why gonzi was excellent but I had
already covered this on video and still
the best performance probably still is
has some tournament victory in 2009 in
China nanjing china the poor poor spring
tournament where he scored them out of
10 games it was a six-player double
round-robin on tournament out of 10
games he scored 8 points plus six
winning all his white games and an
additional black game which totals for
3000 rating performance 3000 seems a bit
of an outlandish figure but you better
get used to that I think gardens rating
of 2870 pretty much if he wants to keep
this rating more even yeah try to
improve it he will need to play some of
those 3,000 performances so just a given
but okay he's improving its rating
simply by refusing to play below 2800
which is also it's simply simply amazing
all right let's get to this game um it's
the final round game so Carson's
tournament
which victory was already fixed like
three games before the end of the
tournament because he was dominating so
much but in the final round game you
certainly wanted to try to win to get
this fine 3000 performance and at the
time this also meant that he would cross
the 2800 bahria he hadn't yet done that
it's 2009 remember for years ago so
let's see default played his opponent is
some top Russian Grand Master Dmitry
Yaakov ankle at the time Yaakov ankle
was probably Russia's number two behind
chronic he had excellent run in 2008 in
2009 but to be honest in this game he
didn't have his best day but still it's
a very nice display from thousand two to
punish him play that it's not really up
to the point let's see what happens we
have a Queens gambit declined and Yakko
bank was playing this early Bishop e7
line a line that yeah basically was
getting popular starting in the 1960s
played by by Geller mostly but also by
other top players their ideas to avoid
the classical exchange variation which
always some has had the reputation of
being slightly better for wide until
this day this reputation stance I always
recommend white players to to play the
exchange ever they have the opportunity
simply a nice line for white and there
should be seven is designed to prevent
this specific move order because now
white cannot put the bishop on g5
obviously if he wants to get to the pawn
structure of the exchange you can still
exchange but put the bishop on
for this is exactly what cars in clay
diem also a good line for white or
something to be recommended however I
think black has better equalizing
chances in this line that in the
classical exchange Yakov echo not played
the move c6 which is very normal for
this structure there's an alternative in
Knight f6 in fact this is the move that
I play in this position I have from
plateless lines black numerous times my
idea is to play play the slide which is
a completely different approach because
after queen bee three you go for a
sacrificial idea to give up b7 it's a
very different from what jackie evancho
is playing he played c6 and after the
Queen c2 there's also III white camp
like Quincy 20 III III ever allows
Bishop f5 which is not at the end of the
world one key point of whites play and
the move that was introduced by mohammed
minik is g-form gaining space on the
King side and even continuing to to gain
space this is the alternative but
Carlson shows us another way he plays
Quincy to also good controlling at five
so that the bishop cannot move them ya
know your comic who plays an interesting
move um a move that looks a bit weird at
first because it seems like black is
losing a tempo Bishop to d6 move this
bishop again yeah in fact it is it's it
is a loss of tempo it's going to d6 and
two moves but it serves a purpose this
is strong Bishop and you like to
exchange at and there's an additional
idea we see that captured not much else
III and 97 this is
one idea connected to visually 63 e74
this night and this prepares the move
Bishop f5 you would like to get this
Bishop out on ideally exchange it for
everyone so very logical play by a black
girl Bishop b3 of course you want to
prevent Bishop f5 and now Yaakov Anka
plays the move b6 and to be honest I
don't like that move the ideas to play
Bishop asics but it just we concern the
queenside I had um looked at this line
some years ago when I prepared the
Queens gambit declined and in fact them
I came to the conclusion that if I play
this position I would play Queen f6 here
intending again to play Bishop f5 um
this is my idea fifth and for this
position I'm not sure if it is a great
idea it's yet another Queen move but you
really want to play Bishop f5 I didn't
find a refutation or anything but it's a
possible alternative to to be 6v6 is not
fatally bad I just say that I don't like
the idea much of course the some
exchange is something that you yeah that
you like to do but you lose time and you
you weaken your queen side okay castles
take stakes and believe it or not the
next move is of vital importance and yak
Evancho no place on ya plays a very
natural looking move but ed indeed leads
to trouble already he should now castle
and after that I think the position
should be yeah slightly better for white
the term it is nothing special the
position is slightly better for what it
because of the slightly weakened Queen
side if you had the pawn on b7 that
would be completely equal and nothing to
fear at all for black and here I'd say
that white is slightly better you can
think of various ideas you can play rook
c1 try to get something against the palm
or you can still play for you for this
is possible try to open up the center
after capturing night x you can play
Queen d5 and this is a decent position
we see what yaku encoded in the game is
similar but has a concrete problem the
plate 97 and now after you form you
cannot really capture and this is the
vital point because after taking queen d
5 White has a very strong move Queen a3
and this is what yaakov ankle probably
overlooked now you have yeah this is
basically lost like already very very
hard now to make a move you cannot
castle because it's evan is just hanging
first attacking here and then taking e72
bot do play Knight c3 first after
capturing rupee eight black would get in
fall back don't want that so black
cannot Castle sin what what are you
going to do I'm threatening rookie 193
and this is a disaster the relatively
best line is something like that check
yeah like s terrible shape white just
the text with all pieces and thus King
is terribly
is placed what is the almost winning in
this position also have d5 breaking up
the center terrible yeah the problem is
okay you cannot take so on what should
black play there is a pure castle and
now why plays a 5 and this is what like
really wanted to avoid to give right
this space advantage and the problem is
that we now get a very typical type of
position we've got four pawns for white
against three pawns on the kingside so
white has a majority on the King side
and it is often very very dangerous
business for black to defend against
such a majority because if white manages
to get this majority rolling it will
almost always mean that also your king
is going to come under fire and we see
in the game on that yaakov enko refuses
to play one key defensive move and this
already em means that again and it's so
straight forward from here that it's
really amazing but countless players
from Narnia completely logical he plays
a rook to e1 of course supporting those
pawns the roofs are perfectly placed on
a one and everyone because the f porn is
the mr. poem that wants to get into the
game this is why the point the rook is
fine on everyone and we see this is
going very very quickly rook e8 ok and
now strong night h4 very straightforward
play f4 f5 No and what should black do
I think here or in the next two or three
moves he really must play f5 to stop
that f4 f5 advance it looks very ugly
this move because at the moment you have
your queen as the blockading square for
this pensar but there is no choice you
need to play the F pawn I'm on a good
day you even managed to play 936 and our
came hard to believe you managed but you
need to play a 5 here on the next moves
let's see what happens if plate 96 which
is probably still okay but we see later
why just captures of course note that
not a 5 it's not really to the point it
looks nice but what you want to do is to
push the f porn there's also an
additional problem not a form and now
you need to move the Queen to a square
where you don't want to go let's say
here and now we even g6 the student
really didn't really help 96 now is also
answered by by this quite annoying move
yeah and turn and we are close to a draw
him something like that check it's just
very simple take on g6 Queen recaptures
okay you don't want to trade queens of
course we need to yeah why don't why not
put the Queen trade simply the heart
pushes will endanger blacks King and you
want to have the Queen's on for that
later a creature eight in the end game
when you have a winning completely
winning and gambits this is ok but here
trading would just ease the pressure
this is why 22 is clearly the best move
here black again and had the possibility
to play the F porn at five he didn't do
that played nine of eight f4 and I think
now it's really the decisive mistake
like here really really needs to play a
five and it's really strange that I
avantco refuses to play this move it
looks and I know it doesn't look like a
move you are enthusiastic about but you
just just need to block this pawn no
simply no other way to play play the
Queen f5 and this is not really a
blockade because yeah the next move of
course 91 it's very simple chess but
very effective 93 pushes the Queen away
and then you play a five played f6 this
was probably the idea night three Queen
back and now the next improving move
Queen d3 simply preparing now night at
596 yeah and what time should like do it
sir it's very difficult to defend he
tries where the tactical way takes on e5
which after d takes d5 of course gives
white immensely dangerous pawns but he
had a direct idea plate 96 and he wants
to go to reform traffic how to play in
fact this is met by a direct tactical
shot and 595 queen deform at first you
think our waiter this isn't this isn't
too clear 94 this is a nice night on e
form but Carlton had seen beforehand
that now why it has a tactical shot if
you like to treat it as a small exercise
you can stop the video to look here it's
not difficult but still something that
you can use for training calculating
little lines okay i'm going to show the
move now what can just take on d5
yeah very very nice little tactic like
recaptures you just take you for
utilizing the pin and another point is
after night to see five first you think
oh wait this is a pin right the night
cannot move White has the strong move f6
intending f7 and now like simply losers
there's no defense whatsoever against
those those magic bones for example
let's say this move check yeah and this
is simply deadly something like that
they have all these sides this is what
ya cahuenga plate and now simply queen
takes d4 and white has one upon and the
worst thing is look at those pawns it's
just terrible they are just just pushing
forward yeah black decided to to
exchange Queens there's simply no
defense IAM anymore group takes and the
rook t6 yeah and now it's easy you just
need to push the pawns try to promote
the two passes basically and of course
you need the g porn for that so g 4g
five and yeah first improve a bit more
there's no need to to rush things you
could also think about f 6 cm tank term
it's not so clear how to now continue
you can try a rookie one but why not
first improve the king don't rush he's
in no hurry first improving the king
improving the pawn chain and now you can
push yeah like an outtake only six pack
still faces the unstoppable f1 check
played the check iam check and after
King edge 1 resigned a very simple game
I mean it looked like um white wasn't
doing anything special yeah this is
probably not a true why didn't play any
great brilliant move for years to
remember but this is really typical of
Calvin games he plays he plays a very
good moves very clean moves they are all
completely to the point and sometimes
they just lead to this very one sided
games where often just one failure of
the opponent simply here we have yahoo
venko or simply not playing f5 I mean
after a five white also hasn't has an
edge but he will not be wiped out and
after black fails due to to play this
defense and just goes for Queen a five
it looks like looks like a game from a
simultaneous display where one side is
just completely dominating the other and
not like a top top GM game it's um yeah
effects a lot of cars games from this
nanjing tournaments and look like that
to be honest he was simply in such an
outstanding form that dumb any kind of
inaccurate move by the opponents and led
to disaster could easily have chosen one
of the other games I just liked the the
simplicity of this game and also the
little detail here that castles is the
much better mood than 97 because of as
mentioned after ninety seven e4
this is Queen a three this is also not
not untypical of cardinals games here
out of outwardly harmless-looking
positions like that it looks completely
harmless this worldwide would did what
why did hear they're still um some
poison and this in these positions and
it's very easy to step into that why not
play 97 first and then castle and this
little um yeah inaccuracies they they
pile up and one or two of those center
yeah he will punish you very very very
very fiercely so for those kind of
inaccurate moves alright i hope you
enjoyed this game it wasn't done a very
spectacular one but still something to
remember the four against three points
that that happened here and this kind of
strategy to push the pawns something you
can probably use in your own games if
you have a similar structure alright i
hope you enjoyed this series 20 games of
top-level chest from the two contestants
of the upcoming match um yeah after the
release of this video there are only two
days till the first game and i hope we
will have a good competitive match an
exciting match maybe even one that gets
to two to a tiebreaker you never know
people ask me about my personal guess
about the match result um yeah i can i
can really say that John I like Arnold's
play anthem and am a fan but I think
it's time form constitute to win the
tightly he's the best player and I
expected him to win the match why if
it's um yeah by two points I would say
maybe plus two maybe only plus one I
don't think
don't think more it I think it very much
depends on the first couple of games if
Carson wins an early game I think the
match is basically over if however our
managers to win one of the early games
and takes a lead then I'm i would start
to bed on the ship I think I'm in the
last games that he played him he really
didn't look like himself he lost to very
drastic games recently against Carlton
and I think it would help him mentally
to win a good game and get to get
damaged rolling remember it's just 12
games the winners immensely immensely
important and if Adam manages to score
the win and take the lead I think as a
good chances to maybe to maybe win the
match the upper opposite however means
that it's over if Calvin takes the lead
I think the metra cyst is done but we
would see what happens you if you never
know you never know alright thanks for
watching hope you enjoyed the series and
i'll be back on the ninth ninth of
november with the coverage of the first
match game thanks for watching